all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to my morning coffee thought I
have to do an Uber today because I could
not do it you know I'm running around
doing all this stuff
um so today we're going to talk about
the biggest travesty in society
what is really hurting us as a people
okay
um and a lot of you guys want have
always said Pearl why don't you offer
Solutions
why don't you give us like more
solutions for society so today I'm gonna
give you guys the best solution that
will fix society and all of its problems
stop having sex with whales
guys guys guys this is the problem why
does lizzo think she's a 10.
genuinely why does lizzo think she's a
10. she wouldn't think she was a 10. if
there wasn't oh no I dropped my phone
hold on sorry guys if there wasn't
somebody screwing her blessing am I
lying
am I lying
what
look at guys guys
if she's over 200 walk away walk away
because what happens is you get these
like obvious twos and threes and fours
and they start to think that they're
eights nine and even tens and they're
300 pounds this is crazy this is madness
so I'm like who is screwing this lady to
make her think that she's 300 pounds
okay
um
so I just this is a solution now I know
what you guys are gonna say pearl
you got to put this on the women right
obviously
you got to tell the women to stop
opening it up like busting that
open whatever
guys is that gonna work is it come on
like the whales are gonna do what whales
do and that's go after the fit men
that's what these ladies tell me time
and time to get on their show they're
big but they won't date a guy that's big
and all you thin men will still screw
them knowing damn well you ain't wife in
that and
it really just brings big problems in
society because we've got all these
delusional women so
um
yes guys
please stop
screw in the whales
thank you